we we went into some detail on what was
going on
in the markets yesterday because what's
going on in the markets
more so than usual is reflecting what's
been going on in our politics not just
for the last two months but for the last
four years five years what happened
yesterday
is a a bunch of people on reddit
gathered together they saw that a big
hedge fund had a massive short position
on gamestop which is not a valuable
company in and of itself
but the the institutional investor had
this short position meaning they were
betting against the stock
so all these reddit guys went in and put
their money
on game stock game stop rather game stop
stock
and that drove the price up as the price
went up the people with the short
positions have to shell out more and
more money
and the the premise of these redditors
is they were willing to remain
completely insane
longer than the financial institutions
could remain
solvent and this would result in them
making a bunch of money
so it was all going according to plan
gamestop hit up to i think 460 dollars
there were other
not very valuable companies that were
also going through the roof companies
like amc
blackberry nokia and then
robinhood which is the retail investing
app
stopped letting people buy the stocks
they just cut it off you could sell you
were allowed to sell
because selling helped all those
institutional investors but you couldn't
buy
and so you're you're if you're an actual
day trader if you're going in
you're really banking on this to make
money and it's not just some kind of
frivolous thing
what robin hood did was prevent your
ability to to make money and really
really could have cost you a lot of
money too
seemed totally unprecedented i mean
especially because you're talking about
the combination
of big tech this kind of retail
investing so the ceo of robinhood goes
on cnbc
cnbc anchors sitting there says what on
earth are you please tell me
what's going on today and the ceo didn't
have a great answer
explain what happened today thank you
for having me on the show again
uh andrew um so what happened today
was as you pointed out we had to make a
very difficult decision
it's been uh it's been a challenging day
we made the decision
uh in the morning to limit the buying
of about 13 securities on our platform
so to be clear uh customers could still
sell
uh those securities if they had
positions in them
and they could also trade in the
thousands of other securities
on our platform so it was a difficult
decision
um and uh and and that's what we had to
do as part of normal operations
hold on wait hold on there i i was sort
of with you
until the end you said this was a very
difficult position a
very difficult decision rather and and
so therefore one might imagine it was a
sort of unusual position
that he was in and then at the end he
says but this was part of normal
operations
part of normal operations nothing about
what happened in the markets yesterday
was normal
and there is absolutely nothing normal
about telling your
customers that they can't buy the stocks
they want to buy and they can't buy the
positions in in the market that they
want to buy
of course not now the the word customer
here is a little interesting because
we all think of ourselves if you're
using a retail investing app you think
that you're the customer
but you're not the customer you're not
really paying for this sort of thing
who are the cut the customers are the
people within
the financial establishment and i love
i love his excuse he goes yep there were
13 assets that you weren't you weren't
allowed to buy positions in that was
very difficult
but you could buy positions and all the
other ones you know you couldn't buy
buy positions in the the assets where
you would have made money
but you could buy other stuff why can't
what's the big deal you could still buy
positions in assets that might lose you
money
just not the ones where you could have
made historic gains
no big deal right so this to the the guy
in the cnbc to his credit uh this was
not good enough so he says uh hold up
wait what
uh come again but explain then why did
you do this
did the sec call you and tell you you
had to do this
was there a problem inside the company
in terms of liquidity in terms of the
amount of deposits that you had
uh to to put in in front to the
exchanges what led to this
sure and let me let me explain exactly
how this works
um oh first of all i want to address
some of the
misinformation that's been out there
because there's a lot of it um
we absolutely did not do this at
the direction of any market maker or
hedge fund
uh or anyone we route to or other market
participants
the reason we did it was because uh
robinhood is a brokerage firm
we have lots of financial requirements
including
sec net capital requirements and
clearing house deposits
so that's money that we have to deposit
at various clearing houses
so some of these requirements uh
fluctuate
quite a bit based on volatility in the
markets
and they can be substantial in the
current environment
okay fair enough so you know all of the
kind of financial jargon aside here
what he seems to be saying is yeah we we
needed
more money than we had we needed more
cash than we had on hand so you know we
had to shut this down but then the
interviewer goes on he says so this is a
liquidity issue
right this is just an issue you didn't
have enough cash and
and the ceo of robin hood says no no it
wasn't a liquidity issue no it's all
good it's all good it's not that it's
but we definitely didn't do it at the
behest of any institutional
investors or hedge funds or market
makers or people it was just
just normal normal operations and that's
why it was such a
difficult decision not
very convincing i don't know anything
about the inner workings of robin hood
and i don't know very much about the
financial services industry either
but i know that that answer did not
convince the guy on cnbc
and i don't think it convinced anyone
else either this
seems rigged it just seems rigged
it it it is something that uh
i i think has been a long time coming
for people in politics because well i'm
getting a great deal of enjoyment out of
the craziness of the markets and how
funny this is and all the memes and
everything
there's a new one they they actually now
are running up the price of something
called
dogecoin which is just a meme it's like
a fake cryptocurrency and they ran that
price up and now i think they're
you're not even allowed to buy that now
all of this manipulation of the markets
this is forgetting us for a second the
the stocks themselves and the assets
themselves the right has needed a
reckoning on this for some time
we on the right love markets we love
free markets
we think free markets are a wonderful
tool for human flourishing
totally some people on the right however
have made an idol
out of free markets a free market is not
merely an instrument
to their broader political ends the
market has become the
end in and of itself and that is
ridiculous and sophomoric but also
just deeply deeply wrong because
and we've had this conversation with
regard to speech we'll have it now with
regard to markets
there is no such thing as a perfectly
free market
it doesn't exist just like there's no
such thing as perfectly free speech
there are always limits on it whether
it's limits on fraud or limits on
threats or limits on sedition or limits
on obscenity or limits on
this that or the other thing which has
have always existed in every single
society and always will
there is no such thing as the perfectly
free market there are constraints on the
market you saw this yesterday
sometimes we like to use the phrase of
adam smith we talk about the invisible
hand of the free market which to me is
sort of magical thinking
and there there's some use of that that
image but
it's it's not you know religious fact
and i think people have turned it into a
religious idol
yesterday we did not see the invisible
hand of the free market we saw the
visible fist
of a rather unfree market
now i pointed this out and someone
actually had the audacity to say
yesterday
they responded they said the free market
part michael
is that you don't need to use robinhood
you don't need to use robinhood a
so what you're really telling me is
build your own broker dealer you just
got through telling me
you just got through telling me that if
i don't like twitter i can build my own
twitter then we did build our own
twitter it was called parlor
and then they shut that one down too
they kicked it out of the app stores
then when that didn't work to totally
kill it they kicked it off of its web
services
whoopsie daisy build your own web
services build your own app store build
your own iphone
build your own domain registrar build
your own
internet build your own society that's
what they're saying here well build your
own broker dealer
well build your own stock exchange well
build your own securities and exchange
commission
well build your own government that's
what we're trying to do guys that's what
we're trying to do
and the way you do that is you engage in
politics but for
for so long the the market idolaters
have come in the people with this
extreme i don't even want to call it a
libertarian view because it's unfair to
libertarians
but this kind of shallow ridiculous
talking point view from the 90s and
2000s
that conservatives can never ever exert
political power that the people give us
because it would disturb my wonderful
cherished free market or something and
therefore we need to just
do nothing the only the only kind of
politics we can have is negative well
where did that get us where did that get
us now
even those very fundamentalists are
saying yeah build your own government
i i fully intend to do that i fully
intend
to get political power in
this country through political means
and get the people to elect good
candidates and then to exert that kind
of political power
against the rigged system that we are
seeing
we've seen it just in the last couple
days in the markets but we've seen it
much more broadly
over the past decades this robin hood
ceo
who was shutting people out of making
investments yesterday
but only specific investments where they
could have made a lot of money
he is being sued as of course he should
be there is at least one class action
against him there's probably going to be
multiple
maybe they'll all converge brandon
nelson who's a retail investor from
massachusetts filed a suit in the
southern district
of new york claiming that the company
violated quote the implied covenant of
good faith and fair dealing with its
customers
when it restricted them from making
transactions on high-yield
assets quote on or about january 27th
robin hood in order to slow the growth
of gamestop and
deprived their customers of the ability
to use their service abruptly
purposefully willfully and knowingly
pulled gamestop from their app meaning
retail investors could no longer buy or
even search for
gamestop on robinhood's app
good i'm glad i think this guy probably
committed
serious crimes not even just a breach of
contract for the users of robin hood
it seems like these were pretty serious
financial crimes that were committed
yesterday
that kind of market manipulation is
absurd whether or not he'll be held to
account
for this i don't know because it just
seems like a rigged game right so it
seems like some people are held to
different standards than others
this is why i don't believe this whole
gamestop dogecoin
amc market thing i don't think it's rich
versus poor i know there
were some conservative commentators
yesterday who were
afraid that we were delving into a kind
of rich versus
poor 99 versus 1 kind of
almost leftist sounding dialogue about
this
i don't think it's rich versus poor
first of all i don't think these
redditors
who drove the stock prices way up i
don't think they're poor i think they're
they're very intelligent obviously they
are fairly sophisticated they know how
to search for these kind of positions
that institutional investors have they
are smart enough to realize if someone's
got a huge short position
and you can gather a million people or
two million people
to go in and pump up this asset then
you're going to
create a short squeeze and if you hold
on long enough then the assets going to
go up unless there's market manipulation
from the outside
all of this to say these are not idiots
all right and
and one aspect of
reddit and twitter and social media that
makes it difficult to speak about this
in a
in a sort of scientific data-driven
statistical way is people have anonymous
accounts right so you just you can't
you can't know that much about these
people if you're just trying to
analyze it from the outside but in my
own experience
the plural of anecdote will have to be
data here in my own experience
the the people i know who spend a lot of
time on reddit or twitter
and who have anonymous accounts are very
smart and they're not living in their
mom's basement and they're not waiting
to eat the chicken attendees or whatever
the memes say that they are
they're pretty urbane people many of
whom have kind of normal jobs
who go to normal cocktail parties who
have a kind of
sophisticated yuppie-ish way of living
but who just
realize how corrupt this system is
right they they take this the same view
i was describing yesterday on the show
when we said is it about elitism or
populism i said when we have a good
elite i'm an elitist
when we have a corrupt elite i'm a
populist of course
i want to be governed by good wise
serious virtuous people
elites could be that and in that case
works for me but when the elites are not
that
then i'm i'm with buckley you know when
he says that i'd rather be governed by
the first 2000 people
in the boston phone book than the
faculty of harvard college bill buckley
was the same way he was an
elitist of sorts except when the elite
was totally
decayed and degraded and debased i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]